all right
here we go so hello everybody
always a joy to see people in the chat
already well it looks like the
conversation's been going around
going on for a little while already in
the chat so um
yeah so i've got a few announcements to
make
before we start on the question period
um biggest announcement i guess
is that as you know oh symbolic memes is
there if you guys have not seen
the memes that this channel has been
putting out it's been
it's hilarious very very funny means
very funny meme so check it out some
some pretty funny stuff
so um uh so today
uh jordan peterson put up the discussion
that i had with him on audio and then
tomorrow
he will also put up the video part of
the video
version of the discussion and so i'm
pretty happy until now the reactions
that i've gotten from people
are kind of what i was hoping the
discussion is quite uh touching
and surprising jordan just doesn't hold
back like he just goes all out in terms
of talking about
the difficulties that he's going through
the questions that he has and
um and so i was really happy about that
discussion it was
i would say that the discussion that i
that's gonna that's going up with jordan
it's pretty much if i could have had any
discussion with jordan peterson in
public
this this was the discussion that we had
we went over several things we talked
about in private but then
we even explored some new territories so
i'm pretty happy about it and i think
that
and i mean we'll see we'll see what
happens but i feel like
i feel like it's going to have a
positive impact on people so i'm pretty
happy
so if you want to listen to it already
you can check it out on his audio
podcast and if not you can wait tomorrow
to watch the video version so so yeah so
that's that's going on right now
um okay so last month okay so
one of the things i'm trying to do right
now is there a lot of stuff
happening i'm having the whole website
redone and uh let's say also kind of
working with a marketing company to look
at strategies like what are the best
strategies to kind of present my message
the best way i can
one of the issues i've had is that i'm
all over the place you know i'm an
artist i'm
doing this this graphic novel project
i'm doing these videos a podcast there
is now
a blog on the website and i also started
a new podcast with
jp marc marco those you might have seen
him on my channel a few times he also
has his own facebook channel
jp is the editor for the symbolic world
blog but we've decided to start a french
podcast
and so we're hoping once a month maybe
more who knows we'll see but we're going
to
put up some french content going over a
lot of the english content that i've
been doing for years
um and maybe doing it in a more
systematic fashion jp
is a more systematic person in general i
just kind of make videos and go from
idea to idea and hopefully you guys can
gather
some kind of pattern in what i'm doing
um so uh so yeah so that's going on so
one of the things that i'm trying to do
is because
of youtube's pressure let's say
because of the the massive pressure we
felt in social media in the past few
months
i mean the past few years but it's
accelerated of course in the past few
months as well
um is i'm really trying to focus on the
website so that if ever my youtube
channel goes down
then we'll have an email list we'll have
another platform that we can use we can
put up the videos on bid shoot
they're already going up on bid shoot
but you know you know if
if youtube goes down then we can promote
those videos so what i want from people
i'm hoping from people is that they
go to the website and subscribe to the
website there's a
down at the bottom of the website
there's a subscribe field and you can
subscribe there for free
and you will be getting notifications by
email
of any new content that is coming out on
the symbolic world
so uh so i'm really trying to focus that
and in order to do that i'm i
did a raffle this this month and i'm
gonna do another one this month as well
and so uh for all the patrons that are
supporting you financially
uh you get like two two chances in the
raffle and then
for the people who are subscribed just
subscribe you get one chance so
i don't know i didn't even look at who
was who but the names of the two people
that won
um the first one is
a sweater that is the image of
everything sweater
black black sweater and that one was won
by someone named adam white
and then the second was dropped
was a saint michael say michael
uh tote bag and that is what was won by
someone named
charles streetsell so both of you guys i
will
send you an email in the next few days
and you'll probably get it this month
all right and so this month i'm doing it
again so please sign up to the website
this is why i'm doing this so that so
that so that if if the apocalypse
happens we'll have
more time to uh to continue the symbolic
world
discussion so uh all right so
so i'm gonna have two chances again like
i said two two things
one is going to be a nice light gray uh
seven days
six days of creation t-shirt and the
second one is also a t-shirt
uh is a black griffin
t-shirt so so sign up this month and uh
next month i will do another raffle and
i'll do this for a few months
because i really want people to sign up
all right so
that is that is the announcements for
now
all right so i'm happy to see brad and
lisa are there and i see
neil degrade is there dear paul robbins
you guys check out the conversation i
had with him
he's been really involved in symbolic
world discussion and his last album has
all these
really fascinating prophetic uh sayings
that just came true so you know when we
say symbolism happens there's some
people that can even you know intuit
this the patterns
and uh and somehow predict the future
so all right here we go so i'm going to
start on the symbolic world
website and uh i'm feeling kind of spry
tonight so hopefully i'll have an energy
level
uh that's up that's up uh
that's up all the time here okay so here
we go
let make sure that i've got all the
comments up because i don't want to
forget anything
all right here we go all right before
before that there was one last thing i
wanted to show you guys because
uh because teespring sent me this really
cool like uh
watch the fool's water bottle so i'll be
drinking from my wash to fools water
bottle
and someone noticed and pointed out that
the great thing about having it on a
water bottle is that every time you
drink
you're actually turning the fool and the
king so on the design this design
i put like some are the king on top and
some are the full on top
turning so just having fun with that
stuff it's a lot of fun
okay here we go so
symbolic world website tan moose man
asks
what is the relation between sacred
liturgical language from other languages
what makes some languages holy and
others not with the key differentiating
principle
other than tradition perhaps um
well i would say that there's something
about
ancient languages that really do does
make them particular like if you look
for example of the difference between
the hebrew let's say and uh greek and
latin
hebrew has an idiom
there's the the the hebrew letters
are idioms and there are even actually
hieroglyphs hieroglyphs originally and
so
each hebrew letter is visually
represents something
and so the the letters also have
uh numerical value and so
there's an idea let's say in kind of
jewish and hebrew hebraic language that
the actual constitution of the words are
meaningful that is that there's
something about how the letters are
brought together
that because each letter actually has a
meaning it's not just an arbitrary
signifier which is pointing to uh to uh
to a sound
then there's actually other meanings
that are can be
held together by word and that words the
constitution of the words themselves
are part of their meaning and so there
are languages like that like for example
chinese
um and there are other languages like
that where the relationship
the the fullness of meaning which can be
contained in the words
related to numbers and related to a kind
of poetic reality within the word itself
you know is something that is
absent from languages that are purely
phonetic and so
greek and latin use a semitic alphabet
but they they kind of took a semitic
alphabet after they lost their own
writing
so you can imagine maybe their own
writing before had a more kind of
idiomatic
or you know um
poetic structure within the very very
words
whereas now it's just this kind of
arbitrary signifying
but one of the things that phonetic
languages do
is that they offer more power and so
because of this kind of uh because of
the phonetic structure
it offers more possibilities in terms of
how those languages can expand and so it
makes sense that for example
a language like greek would be in latin
would have been used
for christianity because christianity
was meant in a way to kind of
fill up the world and kind of go to the
edge of the world and so there it seems
that there's to me at least there's a
relationship
from the movement from hebrew into greek
and latin and then into the rom
the roman languages you know the
romantic languages and all these other
languages that there's this kind of
movement
from this extremely highly qualitative
thing
and then moving out into filling up the
world while i think keeping
and preserving the uh the um
or containing the the deeper meaning
there
in there as well but it's probably very
good to know hebrew i think that's one
of the
advantages that uh moderns us moderns
have is that we have more access to uh
to hebrew than um then did the ancients
so the old testament
but i mean a lot of people are gonna
knock me because
a lot of people are really really
attached to the septuagint and i
think the septuagint is amazing and i
think that it has a very important
part to play but nonetheless i think
that there's something about
the very ancient languages which is uh
very highly qualitative in what they can
contain within their their structure so
hopefully that answers that
so nomad in socks asks
would you mind going over the macro
vision of what the symbolic world view
does for individuals and groups who use
it
i've been trying to sort of map your
philosophy as a whole
and we'd love if you could try to string
it all together from top to bottom
and so so one of the things that
having a symbolic worldview does
is
at least now the thing is that in an
ancient world you really didn't need to
have an explicit symbolic world view it
was kind of like the water you bathed in
and i've often said that there's a
trade-off that i'm doing
and i we have to understand the price of
that trade-off which is that as the
symbol
as we reach the edge of the symbolic
world as we get into the
to the margin of that very pattern it is
as the
the as the clown world and all this
upside-down stuff and all the marginal
identities start to to scream loud you
know all the dragons are
screaming and all the gargoyles are
laughing so as we reach that world
it becomes harder and harder to to see
how all of this is connected
and so having this having the symbolic
world view i hope
is a way to kind of jump start the
engine and get people to kind of get a
macro vision
of both helping them
understand how this breakdown that we're
going through is actually connected
to a larger pattern which is really
which is linked to a center
which is linked to the relationship
between heaven and earth all of these
more traditional patterns and so that's
really what i'm hoping to do
with helping people have a symbolic
worldview
but um but it's important to understand
that
one of the reasons why the ancients
didn't talk explicitly about symbolism
the way we talk
explicitly about symbolism doesn't mean
that it wasn't there it means that it
was taken for granted
so when we have to start to explain
symbolism instead of just
living it instead of imbibing it in
ritual forms imbibing it
in in songs in music in
you know in all kinds of events and and
architecture all of this
then when we have to start to explain it
it's actually bad news
um but that's where we are
so so what i'm hoping is that regaining
a symbolic worldview
will will at least for some people
be a kind of a cpr
a kind of cpr to kind of help people
breathe again
and rediscover the from the inside
uh how to participate in reality you
know in a in a fuller way
so hopefully that answers that so luca
askovich
asks what is the symbolism of genesis 34
man you guys the chapter where dina's
daughter dina
the daughter of jacob is raped by sesham
seshem and his father strike a deal so
that jacob's family
and hamur's family intermarry later
shechem
his father and every male in the city
that they
resided in were killed by levi and
simeon how did this connect
how did this story connect to other
stories of the bible and ultimately to
christ let me just do something here for
a second
i want to get the chat to be popped out
man you guys that story that's one of
the toughest stories in the scripture
but it's also one of those stories
that says a lot about how reality works
um and so you can understand that story
as let's say explaining the relationship
between
identity and the strange and identity
and the the foreign
um you have to be careful like sometimes
i talk about the idea of the foreigner
and the foreign
and you really have to understand that
category as a universal category
it's not just about foreigners in the
strict stance is that every identity has
foreigners
to it like every form of group like your
family has
foreigners that is all the strangers
outside that you don't know are
strangers to you and so
it's it's really is a universal category
we have to be careful not to see it too
strictly but
in terms of in terms of uh of
this story um okay
so
the idea is that first of all it's
important to
notice that hamor the father of
seshem means donkey he means ass
that's the first thing to understand
for those who have seen kind of my talk
about the symbolism of christ sitting on
the donkey as he enters into jerusalem
and what that means both for for
let's say for jews and for christians it
has to do with this idea of
the the stranger the impure animal
the the donkey uh as the image of
this strangeness okay and so
the problem the problem is happens at
on many on many sides and so
you could understand it as that which is
outside
taking your possibilities right and so
the the the feminine the female
the sister of of the of the brother the
daughter
she is she represents the possibilities
of that world that you could it could
have been someone's wife
you know it could have been just like
you see in the story of um
of abram and his wife when he goes into
the foreign land and his wife is
taken by the pharaoh okay this is
similar
in terms of the symbolic structure what
it's talking about which is that
uh the the
the the strange can take your
possibilities
and can take them away from you so that
it will
ultimately destroy you right so you
imagine a foreign army on the outside
they ask for tribute they ask for
something and you start to give away
your wealth
to that which is outside and then you
you you starve yourself and you stop to
to uh you stop to uh
you stop to be so you stop to be uh
fruitful and so
you can imagine that so this thing
happens where the stranger
takes the what takes adena by force
and so now jacob tries to
remedy the situation jacob tries to
remedy the situation
by saying is there a way that we can
actually bring
you in and make you in communion with us
so that when you if you engage with us
you're not taking
our possibilities but we're actually
building together and so what he asks
is he asks them to be circumcised and so
when he asked them to be circumcised
he's saying remove the donkey
remove the outside remove the animal
part remove the garment of skin and if
you do that
then we will we will be able to enter
into communion with you
and therefore when you engage our
possibilities it will be a mutual
building
rather than you taking them away from us
and then
and then us losing losing what we have
okay
and so this is this is of course
and so that act by jacob
which is a problematic because because
seshem raped dina and so it's
it's not like there was everything was
balanced at the outset
it's like jacob reaches out and wants to
be in communion with someone who raped
his daughter and then the sons are like
we're not gonna have this and so what it
does is
sometimes i talk about how one excess
leads into another and so
jacob's desire to enter into communion
with someone who raped his daughter
leads to an excess which is the son
saying yeah is that what you want we're
going to slaughter
all of them and so then comes the other
side it comes here comes identity
manifesting itself
as a cut off as like we're going to chop
off
the we're going to we're going to cut
off the margin like we're completely
going to
eliminate the the and so it's like the
image of
of the image of the the sons of jacob
slaughtering the daughters of hamor is a
circumcision
in like a very dark ass very dark
version of circumcision they're like
we're gonna remove this okay
and so how does this relate to christ
this is very very very much related to
christ
christ is is all about trying to
solve the problem of the inside and the
outside
and how it is that so you can imagine
that christ
goes all the way right goes all the way
and is willing to die even at the hand
of the foreigner at the hand of hammer
because he dies at the hands of the
romans he also dies at his the hands of
his own people so that also
all of that is kind of the extremes are
manifesting themselves all at the same
time
but the idea is that christ succeeds
where jacob failed it is where jacob
failed to enter into communion
with the the the stranger
christ succeeds christ
is able to to to to join himself with
rome
with the with those that killed him it
takes a long time and it happens in a
kind of
in in a very deep you know and
bubbling up way but it ends up happening
and then christ takes over
rome and rome it's not that he takes
over it but that christ and rome
actually now end up finally end up being
joined together
and so you could say that the problem
which is set up in this story
the problem of the inside and the
outside the problem of how the eye
outside tends to take what's inside and
then you want to
you want to deal with that either by
entering
into communion with it either by pushing
them away
you know or there's another possibility
which have been to just to
disappear right to be taken up by the by
the outsider
uh and and you can see it in that story
by the way because that's also what's
happening
because when you see from the side of
hammer he's saying
he's like hahaha like we are going to
enter in communion with them and then
and very soon they'll stop to exist and
will basically take up their
identity right and so it's like all of
the dark sides of this problem of inside
and outside
are manifesting itself in that story and
then christ
comes and brings a kind of universal
solution to
to that problem so all right i'm talking
way too much at each question which
means that i'm not going to make it
through
the end of this all right
all right okay so benjamin rva says
before encountering cappella romana's
album lost voices of hagia sophia
it never occurred to me that music in
the past was composed for specific
spaces
the different cathedrals had different
acoustics and would play differently
this made me wonder do you think we
could in the near future offer digital
pilgrimages where people might
experience holistic
historic liturgies and other cultural
practices in their original context
through technologies like vr
might this provide a means to transmit
body cultural practices
that the written word does not would
there be something inherently wrong
about a virtu
virtual eucharist i would say there's
definitely something wrong about a
virtual eucharist
like especially because eucharist isn't
just that you're
you're you're it's it has to be embodied
you have to eat the bread and you have
to drink the wine it's not
there's not it's not a mental activity
it's not a it's not a virtual thing it
has to actually happen
and it also has to happen in communion
with others there's a there's a
there's a reality of like kissing the
cross and kissing
and and and you know kissing each other
and you know
this bowing before each other and the
smell of the incense and all of this
reality which is which is making us have
the the same experience in the same
place i think is very important
you know i mean whether or not someone
would want to create
a a you know a pristine representation
of some ancient liturgy i don't think
that's completely useful
useless but it might not be as useful as
some other people think which is that
tradition is not the same as archaeology
tradition is not the same
real traditional people let's say don't
want to preserve
past things just to preserve past things
that is
you know an ancient church even if it
was hundreds and hundreds of years too
small when it was too small and the
like they had a lot of money and they
would they had donors and they were
capable of of making it bigger they had
no problems
tearing walls down and making it bigger
and renovating it
and re rebuilding it because
because tradition is alive right and
it's like
they also wouldn't want to destroy it
like they weren't looking out to
to break down the past and build up new
things but they also didn't have a
problem with it because the tradition
was a living breathing thing and so uh
so the idea is that if we're if we
couldn't and it would be very very
stupid
to try to revive some
practice that happened in constantinople
you know a
thousand years ago um
if it was just to be kind of very very
historically
uh accurate you know like i said
tradition is a living organic thing
which both looks to the past but is also
not a slave to the to just to the forms
just because they they exist right um so
hopefully that that makes sense um
um
all right okay so josh the mover says
what is the meaning in psalm 50 of the
line
prevail when thou art judged
it seems to suggest god will be judged
is the is this referring to the world's
opinion of christ as when pilate judged
him
i would have to look at the context of
that because i don't i don't necessarily
remember that
like who is that who is that
referring to
all right look i'm sorry i don't know i
don't understand the context enough
to be able to answer you josh sorry
about that
prevail and our judge i would i need to
i would need to take the time to look at
the context sorry about that maybe next
time provide a little more i know i ask
you guys to write
short questions but maybe provide a
little more context because i don't know
that
uh that that song by heart
all right so jane va says what is the
best way for someone new
to the orthodox church to seek a
congregation
in the dc area where i live there are
greek russian coptic romanians here
cantio can excel right
my journey has been raised
fundamentalist protestant rebelled by
becoming anti-religious jdbu
curious about orthodox church any
resources you can offer
i don't wish to stagger into the
orthodox equivalent of a baptist church
um so i mean i would say
i would say the best thing is to contact
the priests uh
the best thing would be to contact the
priest and to kind of see what kind of
church that you're dealing with you know
my i would say like my uh experience
is that often the antiochian churches
and the oca churches the orthodox church
of america
are more are more welcoming to strangers
strangers that aren't part of the ethnic
group that the church is representing so
you know if you have a greek church or a
you know like a romanian church
sometimes it'll all be in romanian and
then
there will be like a more uh ethnic
aspect to the church and so
that it can be fine if you can handle it
but it can also be
alienating it can be difficult so i
would say to see
like if there's a church that the
services are in english that's already
probably a good sign
that they're open to to to newcomers or
open to people that aren't part of their
strict uh group and so that would be
what i would suggest you to do
all right so timothy aspeslaw asked hey
jonathan in roman catholicism
it is allowed to draw jesus christ as
the lamb of god
yes can you talk a bit about why we
don't find these images in the orthodox
church and how that relates to iconology
so this is a more technical question but
i mean it's important and so it i don't
talk about kind of the specifics of
iconography so much
you know just because sometimes it gets
it gets difficult but so
in in the early centuries there was
a um a council called the kinney sex
council
and the kidney sex council was the
council between the fifth and the sixth
ecumenical council
and so in the the kinney sex council had
several aspects but one
of the aspects it had was to say
that in in
christ we have the
let's say we have the antitype of the
prototype and so you can imagine that in
the old testament there were prototypes
of the incarnation
so the lamb of god different images that
could be used to represent
uh to represent christ but with with the
coming of christ we have the real thing
we have the thing itself
we have christ and so we should
represent in images
the image of the person christ and not
represent him
has the antitypes as the
shadows before which were kind of
pointing to
the uh the the messiah so this this was
a
council that that like i said was
between the fifth and sixth ecumenical
council now
this council was never accepted by rome
and so when
the council arrived at the pope's uh
desk
the pope was so annoyed at this
uh this suggestion that that is the
moment where
in the the the catholic uh
in the catholic liturgy right in the
catholic mass it it it always has
when it says a lamb of god that takes
away the sins of the world
that's when it got fixed into the mass
because the pope
was like i'm not gonna let this go
through and so then the pope
actually commissioned to renovate a uh a
church
in which he had he had the lamb of god
portrayed in the more
kind of very in a very uh it's a
elaborate way
and so that separation stayed until
now and so in orthodox churches
sometimes they take that idea
within the kindest sex council and they
actually push it further and so for
example
that you know i i will tend to represent
i'll be very comfortable representing
uh christ in glory with the four
the four uh animals of uh ezekiel
you know as the four evangelists but in
some churches they will they won't do
that they'll only represent the
evangelists
as the the the the people and so
you'll see like in an orthodox church
off and you'll have the dome of christ
and then in the corners of the pentative
that are like the four glories or
the four uh protrusions of christ then
they'll represent the four evangelists
but not
as animals but as as people whereas in
the west that
uh that remain but in the east you still
do find people that will represent
the the four glories as animals and so
that's what it is it was a it was a it
was a
one of those squabbles between east and
west which happened quite early in the
story so uh
so that's less simba less about
symbolism and more about uh
just uh inner inner church squabbles
all right so what is the symbolism of
milk
and honey specifically with regards to
the land of israel milk and honey are
like
let's say you could understand it as as
a
as two graces that are coming from god
you can understand it
as something like two aspects of wisdom
or two aspects of knowledge um
you know one of them is
one of them has to do with the idea of
more like a feeding
let's say directly in terms of what
comes from the mother and then the other
has to do with uh
kind of wisdom which comes from uh
something like the wild right and so one
is from the mother
one is from the the bugs you know one is
from the the
one is from the inside one is from the
outside and so it has to do with this
idea of this
this relationship of how there is
something sweet
there's something feeding and that
there's something sweet that come from
the inside and
also something sweet that comes from the
the outside and so
the ultimate example where you can see
this symbolism
is for example when uh samson
finds honey in the carcass of the dead
lion
this is really showing the symbolism of
honey and so
the idea is that the the lion first of
all is impure
because it's not a uh kosher animal and
the lion is impure also because it's
dead and samson is supposed to be a
nazarite and so he's actually not
supposed to touch
anything dead and he's not supposed to
consume anything impure
and so he finds honey inside the dead
carcass of
the animal and so there and but honey is
kosher so it's important to understand
that it it comes from the wild it comes
from the outside
but it it's also kosher it's also
something that the jews were allowed to
eat
and so it's like from this dead carcass
from
the the the impure the foreign the
strange you know the hammer the the
donkey all of that
that nonetheless in that that fringe
possibility
he finds the sweetness um and so that's
also why
uh john the baptist who lives in the
desert eats bugs
and wears garments of animal skin but
also eats honey
because that's the wisdom that he has
access to it's the
with this kind of wisdom which is hidden
in the outside
so all right
all right here we go so nelson justin
evan
when the bible speaks of the church is
it meant to be interpreted
as one of the catholic orthodox
protestant etc
denominations or does it point to
something like the invisible fellowship
of all true believers
regardless of denomination do you know
of any examples of instantiations of the
pattern
if there is one and so when the bible
speaks to the church it talks about the
one church there's only one church
and and it's not invisible
because the body is not invisible the
body is visible and so
it's a it's a paradox it's a it's a it's
a
sad let's say the fact that the church
is broken or the
it's hard to even say that the fact that
there are these divisions which happen
in the story of the church is a scandal
it's not
normal it's it's something something
which is
shouldn't be accepted it's something
that shouldn't be seen as inevitable
and and and something we have to just
accept right it is a
it is a a sign of our sinfulness
it's a sign of our incapacity to hold
together and so
and so when the bible talks about the
church it talks about
the one there's only one and it's
visible and it's
and it's the body of christ so you know
that's what it is okay so eric says
it would be very interesting to hear you
talk about the divine counsel
the giants are getting some body in
regards to the article by the way god
bless
um and so those who um
who've heard me talk i i'm constantly
trying to get you guys to listen to the
lord of spirits podcast
it is in a way advanced listening it's
advanced listening in the sense that
uh you know father stephen and father
andrew
they really stay in the story pattern
like they really talk about it in a
very mythological story uh
version and so it's it's it's uh
it can it can be intense for kind of
atheists and secular minded people
because it's like all right here are
these
hierarchy of angels and here's this
divine council and god is sitting in his
throne and the
the angels are are worshiping him and
are becoming principalities in the world
and
we're called to be principalities all
right so um
but if you want to understand i've i've
i've said this all the time like you'll
i think someone i think lisa or lhasa
who
who were running the chips the clip
channel
put up a clip recently which is which i
talk about that which is that the
hierarchy
the hierarchy that i talk about in the
world is not a hierarchy of concepts but
is really
a hierarchy of beings and and that's
actually how it
how it works and so you can imagine that
there are beings that
that come up into principalities and
then these principalities
are beings that go all the way up into
the higher higher forms and you can
imagine that at the highest
you have a divine council which is the
closest
beings around the divine the divine uh
the divine throne and those are the
highest principalities in the world they
are the rulers
of all aspects of reality and so the
higher aspects of reality and so
um they also worship they serve but they
also become
they also become the the principles and
so the idea
that father andrew and father stephen
are trying to help people to understand
is that one of the things that happens
with christ is that we are called
to become that to join the divine
council to become
to become principalities in our
participation in christ
and so their their their contention and
i totally agree with it is that
when we talk about the patron saints of
things and the patron saints of
places and of churches that's an actual
reality it's not just a
it's not just a kind of uh like a poetic
desire to name something after someone
we like it's like that
being is acting as a principle
for that for that community for that
church for that
whatever it is that's being named you
know through the name of uh
of a saint and so
there's a competition there's a
competition in the principalities
there's still some struggle in there
you know it's like uh especially as we
become secular and we start to name
things after people
that aren't necessarily in that divine
hierarchy and so there's a competition
there's a war in heaven
and uh and there's a fight between the
principalities and who is actually going
to become
you know the different uh who's going to
name that's how are we going to name
that street how are we going to name
that bridge how are we going to name
these things
this is super important in how reality
lays itself out and how we see
what is ruling in in the world and what
is holding it together
so or participating in its fragmentation
we could say
all right so kingsley says hey jonathan
wondering if you can elaborate more on
how you view modern counseling
approaches techniques cbt psychoanalysis
cetera are there specific counseling
approaches or techniques that you would
deem
harmful um
i probably don't know enough about that
my father is a psychologist by the way i
might have mentioned that before um
one of the things like for example i'll
tell you an interesting thing my my
father right now is using something
called
family systems therapy and he
finds that in this system this this
family systems therapy there's this idea
that
there's an analogy between how a family
works and how
you work in as a person and so there's
this fractal
structure where you have different parts
of you
that have different wills and volitions
and they're
they're fighting amongst each other
they're collaborating and that you have
to be able to bring them together into a
communion
uh in the same manner in which a family
brings themselves into communion
and so my father has been taking up that
approach because he
sees it as coherent with um
with a kind of more traditional vision
of the human person
this kind of fractal reality and more in
in uh let's say in communion with how
the the fathers would talk about the
psyche and all of this
um there are some really good orthodox
books that talk about that there's a
there's a book called
i think it's called orthodox
psychotherapy
i think it's called and then there's
also one of the great books
which was written uh in french actually
um and now i'm gonna forget his name my
goodness
it's called theology of illness
and it's written by a french author and
now i'm gonna forget his name
it's gonna it's horrible and somebody
can remind me in the uh
in the chat what his name is i have it
in there somewhere in my
library
it's called his name is jean-claude
lache man
i hope he never hears this and sees that
i forgot his name
so jacqueline has written a wonderful
book uh
on on spiritual illness and he's a he's
a physician
but he really goes into the church
fathers and how they do the psyche and
how to apply
uh different methods to kind of help
people through their their psychological
problems all right
so david flores says what symbolism has
captured your attention
currently also your ai conversation was
awesome well i hope you enjoyed
the ai conversation uh oh
i mean capturing my attention you know
there's all the covet stuff is hard to
to avoid like the covet stuff is
majorly capturing my attention and so
i'm being very very attentive
to what's going on and the moves that
are happening and what it means in terms
of
of uh of uh
societies of control and let's say
systems of control and systems of
naming and systems of of identification
you know i've been very sensitive to
that and and
how the strange idea that it would be
related to coveton
and vaccines and tracing and all of
these ideas and what i've been thinking
about so
i'm actually working on a video
which will be on the mark of the beast
and uh and so
i'm taking my time because i don't want
to say anything
anything that will people will think is
crazy but i'm probably going to make a
video on the mark of the beast
very very uh soon hopefully this week or
maybe next week
right so from okay mikhail
hi you have said more bad things about
michelangelo's art than rafael and
leonardo have said combined
at the same time you come yourself from
a western background
are you not afraid of she bears coming
after you
have you ever uh rather have you ever
considered rather following the pattern
of the abbot sujra of saint denis who
learned
the text of eastern mystics and
revolutionized western architecture
by sponsoring the birth of the french
gothic or maybe it is exactly what you
do with your youtube channel
yes i i i i think this
suture of sandini is a is a very
important figure in terms of
in terms of understanding what art can
do and understanding its relationship
to to the manifestation of
manifestation of spiritual realities in
the physical world and so
you know it's like the the one of the
reasons why i'm not so afraid
of going after michelangelo is because
he is
he is like everybody sees him as the sum
of the summit
of like western art as like the the
great genius and the great initiator
of everything and honestly like i really
don't
see him that way and so and so i
actually find it quite
kind of funny that i see him rather as
kind of like the the
the beginning of the decline of western
art you know
um so you know i just think that's funny
and
but i really do believe that i really
think that michelangelo's art is uh
has all has everything in it which kind
of came about later
in terms of the the the breakdown of
visual
of a visual reality so
all right so jacob jacob says it is
obvious that we live in the time of
excessive chaos values confusion
gender confusion etc or could it be
argued that it's actually the time of
excessive order
e.g there's no room for any kind of
non-conformism towards the rules
of the outrage crowd one way or another
how was the time before
on balance to the other extremes so that
the pendulum had to swing so far to the
border
is it still the world war world war ii
residue
um and ps are you planning to visit your
wife's homeland in any time in the
future
so my wife is from slovakia and so i
would love to we
we've been there once uh at the
beginning of our relationship but
uh we haven't been there since i was
actually thinking that maybe we could go
there for several months with the kids
so that they
kind of get a sense of that aspect of
their their heritage
so i would love to do that and you're
right your intuition about
the situation right now is very good
because
we know i often talk about the clown
world stuff and how the world is upside
down but
this is the pendulum is kind of there at
the same time so
we there's both a a kind of excessive
you know insane upside down clown world
and there's also
a kind of excessive insane uh culture of
control and so that's why i like this
the joke that how is it that we could
have
uh brave new world and 1984 at the same
time
even though we're watching it happen in
you know before our very eyes
and so that is kind of the weird
contradiction of the 666
symbolism and the the
the system of the beast let's say which
is that in
the desire to control to name everything
right in the desire to kind of have a
all-encompassing system
it also ends up moving out into
the exceptions and let's say featuring
the exceptions
and so it's like this strange
contradiction and but then it also
is leading to it also leading to the
the kind of this is why the upside down
is also a hierarchy it's like an upside
down hierarchy that's why like
the satanic hierarchy you could call it
right that's why
the the the world as it breaks down it
actually
forms like a weird inverted hierarchy
you know rather than just kind of
break down and to you know kind of fall
apart and and spread out so
and so and is it world war ii residue
it's more than world war ii residue it's
just
it's just like you know when we talk
about like fractal patterns and fractal
cycles and
so this is what's going on it's like the
thing that happened before world war ii
let's say let's say uh
communist revolutions weimar and you
know
technological advance all of this weird
stuff
and then identitarianism all of this was
kind of happening
and now it's happening like all of it at
times 10
in terms of maybe not the communist
revolutions but
let's say several aspects are happening
way bigger and so
yeah what does that lead to we'll see
all right cooper hayes says while
dragons may be more real than dinosaurs
where do the fossils fit into the
symbolic worldview
so a good way to understand what fossils
are is that they're residues they're
they're they're residues from from
a world that's gone that's what they are
and so
that's also what dragons are dragons are
also
things that you don't know what they are
that kind of nonetheless
have take up form and then come in and
try to
to devour you and so that's also what
dragons are and so
the there's a it's not arbitrary that
there's a relationship with
with fossils and the vision of dragons
and of these ancient beasts that are
that are
there in the ground and that we don't
remember but they're
they they matter they're there
nonetheless and they're not part of our
world but they end up being part of our
world
by manifesting this kind of fragmented
kind of
animal chaos that is uh that is there
and so
there's a total relationship between the
experience of fossils and the the
categories of the dragon
all right
all right so we're done with the
symbolic world website
and it is 10 to 10.
not bad i have energy these i used to
not be able to go more than like an hour
and now i
think i could probably go for two hours
it should be okay
all right and so here we go with now on
patreon oh i did note like
just for people if anybody's new here
the uh oh
well i wanted to do something before i
move on to patreon
i'm gonna do this right in the middle of
the video so that people actually have
to watch half the video
is that the last patron only video that
i made
is a video on the symbolism of the jesus
prayer
and i made it patron only video and some
people are very
not annoyed maybe some people are
annoyed with me and some people
don't understand why i did that and
the reason is that i've been thinking
about making a video about the symbolism
of the jesus prayer for a while but i
didn't want it to be a public video
on youtube that could be picked up by
the algorithm and that could be promoted
just because it is a very it's a
difficult subject and is not something
that is meant to be
cried out into the stratosphere and so
and so what i wanted to do is to offer
it to people who are more engaged and so
i
put it up for patrons only but also for
people who are on the facebook group
people who are on the discord group and
i told people that they can
share it privately to to those who think
would be interested in
and so right now i'm going to post the
link to that video
in the chat and so because you guys are
here and you guys are involved and
you're watching this
live i also want to make it available to
you guys and like i said
go you can share it to people in private
but please don't let's i don't want this
to be like a public video
right and that's the that's the idea of
this of of why
i made it private and why i kind of
tried to contain it let's say all right
so so it's there in the chat but i will
probably by the end of the discussion
i'll probably delete it from the chat so
that it doesn't end up
in the public video all right guys
okay so now let's go into the patreon
patreon questions
so bjorn olsen asks
i wonder if the inability to hear and
see each other that we are seeing on
both sides of the political sphere right
now
and the general misinformation coming
from every angle regarding the current
situation
is somehow related to the spirit of
confusion
could you elaborate on that how can we
overcome it
i mean i would say yes
that's a good way to understand it i
mean one way to understand it is
is that as we cease to have something
which unites us
then the things that are separate at the
bottom
are going to start to move farther and
farther away from each other right
so think of it as like a wheel or think
of it as a mountain
as you move farther away from the
mountain the points that were close
together at the top
are now becoming further and further
apart and they because they don't
remember
what it is that is bringing us them
together then
they can't see they can't see in the
other
the other part they can't see that that
other part
is linked with them higher up you know
and so what's going on is just
inevitable
it's like like when someone says
something like
multiculturalism is is
is is wonderful it's like what do you
mean like i
it's a very disturbing way of seeing the
world it's like
there's a multi-culture there can be
multicultural there's always been
multi-culture
but that multicultural nonetheless has
to have something which unites it
above there has to be there also has to
be a uniting principle
which will join the different multi
cultures together
or else it's war right or else or else
it's it's
it's conflict or else it's the
incapacity to see
why i should be next to the person next
to me and so
the idea of like diversity in itself or
multiculturalism in itself
it doesn't work it's impossible it's
like a it's a complete impossibility
it can only work if there's something
there's some
principle higher which is joining them
together and so if you look at ancient
empires like if you look at
the byzantine empire it was massively
multicultural
in the sense that there were syrians and
armenians and greeks
and latins and there were different
aspects of society that have their
different
practices and their different guilds and
their different uh
so it had massive variety
but it also recognized something that
united it together
at the top and without that
that what's going on now is inevitable
the
conflict will grow because how can you
if you don't recognize what's joining
you together then
all you can see are enemies all you can
see are people that are different from
you
and ultimately that doesn't
that doesn't work it's not possible all
right
so hi jonathan what is your take on the
symbolism of sealing
as used in scripture for example the
seven seals in revelation
and being marked by god's seal
in ephesians 1 13 my intuition tells me
sealing has to do with being authorized
having a defined traceable origin and
thus following a straight path
please also comment on the seven seals
in revelation and so
well there are different aspects to what
yes there are different aspects to the
seal and so it depends on the context
but
obviously a seal is something which is
like you said it's making it
authoritative and so if you put a seal
on something
it is saying this comes this is
authentic this is the real thing it
comes
it is connected to the thing that sealed
it right and so
if if uh like you write a letter and
then the king puts his seal on the
letter he's saying
i recognize this as my i'm
recognizing this as my word even if the
king maybe didn't write it himself
he's saying i give it authority right
and so that is what the seal
means it means that it comes with the
authority of that which is above
it and so it's like i if you receive the
seal
of god then you have been
bound to god uh
and and your actions and your
the things you do will be manifestation
of that which sealed you
well even if it's your own gestures they
nonetheless will be
will will be uh like will have received
the authority that god
that god has given you so that's the
idea of
the the seals now there's another aspect
of the seal
which is also a holding secret
which is a holding for into the inside
and that's more
has more to do with the idea of
of the seals in revelation so it's the
idea that there are
the seal also like if you have a letter
and there's a seal that
closes it and keeps it shut and it's
only meant to be opened
for a specific reason and so in that
sense
the the idea that let's say
that there are some things within a
structure of authority that are
only for itself that are meant to be
kept secret within
within the organization right that
aren't meant for the outside
and so that will also be will also
receive a seal
in the sense that it will it's like the
seal then becomes like a wall around it
which is saying
this is meant for the inside this is
meant for us
and it has to be contained and so the
idea of the breaking of the seals
is is that let's say these mysteries
when they
get opened up and then they they kind of
pour out onto the world
they they they act let's say
they they don't they act like
wrath let's say it's like that which is
held together inside has a certain
let's say the love of the you can
imagine like the love of the mother
for her children which keeps that inside
and keeps it protects the inside
once that same love gets turned to the
outside
it opens up it can become she bear
like she bear love where now i'm going
to
ravage what is not in the inside and so
the breaking of the seals in revelation
seems to have to do with something like
that
all right
all right so nina moore says i don't
have a question but i'm so stoked
because i just got my
obviously santa claus exist shirt well i
love it and so do my kids well
i'm happy you enjoy it i'm i i had a lot
of fun making that by the way my
daughter
is i designed that with my two daughters
and so my daughter
uh who was i mean i guess at that time
she must have been like seven or eight
she's the one who made the writing she
wrote it down and then
uh with my other daughter who's a little
older she kind of helped me to think of
the design and how to put it together so
that was fun
um all right so jeff dunlop asks
if enlightened culture is de-personing
god becomes high ideals king becomes
constitution father replaced
by money mother replaced by child care
does this system eat itself in the end
does it bring the return of the person
and so
yes i mean it's definitely
it's already happening you know it's
already happening so
um but i think it's not completely
and i think what i'm doing and what
other people like me are doing is part
of that
is part of now showing how
once you once enlightened culture
starts to really take seriously the
person
or to now turn the eye back and try to
understand
the the personal then it starts to lose
its
bearings it starts to lose its uh its
foot
and then then the person is going to
reappear and it's going to start to
re-manifest himself um
so yeah
so nathan hart says can you explain the
story of jacob wrestling god
i've read many interpretations but none
of them quite
capture the powerful mystical condensed
aspect of what happens in that short
moment yeah
because that's a tough story man that's
a that story is difficult
at least i find it difficult to
completely understand
it definitely has something with jacob
it has something to do
with jacob himself and
the problem of jacob you could say
and so it's like you know when when
christ says that the the kingdom of god
comes through violence or comes to those
who take it by violence there's
something about
this idea that jacob is able
to pull the blessing down on himself
and it's something which is like it's
less
especially as a christian it's like the
kind of thing which makes you uneasy
because it really is this idea that
grace comes first but
in that story that's what you get it's
like jacob
jacob wants the blessing and he'll he's
willing to
fight for it and he's willing to to go
all
out and you know he's willing to do all
kinds of things right to get the
blessing
you can think that that's what he's
doing like think about it this way
jacob is wrestling with god when he
steals
the when he steals his brother's
blessing he's like he's willing to do
anything to get it
and so it's it's almost like
most people most people will do will
fight and do anything to get the riches
but what does it mean when jacob the
snake
is willing to do everything willing to
lie
and cheat and do all these things to get
the blessing
it's a very strange story so when jacob
when jacob
uh you know pretends to be his brother
in order to get his father's blessing
he's already doing that at a lower level
and then when he then when then when he
wrestles with the angel
that's what it's showing it's like he's
willing to do anything
in order to get the blessing
and he gets it so
i don't know what to tell you man it's
not i'm not gonna make any theological
pronouncement on that
but that's what it is you know and you
can see it you can see that the story is
structured
so that you realize the relationship
between getting
the blessing from his father through
weird means and then getting the
blessing
you know of of god
through weird means all right
so jonathan morgan says symbolism of the
boogeyman and monsters under the bed
and that's a pretty simple one isn't it
don't you think i mean the sense that
it's like
you're sleeping sleeping is the place
where reason
starts to break down it's a place where
consciousness goes away
uh that's where monsters come from
monsters come from the place where
reason breaks down it comes to a place
where the category system breaks down
when you when you encounter the unknown
and so you can imagine that the
experience of
also being at night and then
going into unconsciousness and then
understanding that the monsters come
from
below in in the in the psyche
but they also come from below just
normally right
the the the crocodile that pops out of
the water and
you know and grabs you this monster that
comes out and and gets you
that image or the snake that pops up and
gets you or
you know the creeping the creeping uh
beast that will
surprise you and so it makes sense that
those monsters would be under your bed
because they're under manifestation
they're at the bottom of the world
they're in the they're in hell they're
in death whatever
however you want to to phrase it so
imagine the world has a hierarchy
of the ceiling then the bed acts as a
level of being and then
under that there's this this unknown
dark chaotic level of being which is
under there and that's where the
monsters are
that's where they come from
all right
so ron wood says an icon that is used
for the surgical purpose has a clear
place and explicit use
but apart from ornamentation how should
art be integrated into the body of a
home
roger scrutin suggested humans don't
need everything to have an explicit use
in the utility sense is this true
symbolically as well
um and so one of the things so there's
several things that
let's say the objects that you put in
your house there are several things that
they can do
uh for sure if they're beautiful and
they're useful
that brings things together and so and
so
for example having a beautiful
vase or a beautiful kitchenware
and having that displayed that can be
something which is kind of
joining things together in terms of not
having things that are arbitrary
there's also a joining
which is related to memory and so the
idea that
in your home you would have objects
that participate in your story or that
help you remember things and so if you
look behind me
like the the basket that is there it's a
basket obviously i don't use it as a
basket
but that basket is is something which
has very intense
personal uh connection to me because
it's a basket that i
that i brought out of a war zone while i
was
having gun while there was gunfire going
over my head i carried my clothes in
this basket
you know to be evacuated and so it's
like that basket is very
strong but i also find it very beautiful
and aesthetic and pleasing so
then i put it up you know and so similar
things that you'll see
around me will have some connection and
so
my wife and i both my wife and i we
really don't like
having arbitrary art in our house and so
the art that we have is usually
connected to something
connected either to memory connected
made by
a friend made by made or that the
subject is something that we care about
and that is close to us in some way so i
think that the closer you get to that
the better it is for creating a coherent
space
um but there's also decoration is not
an uh uh is his something
decoration is something and so
decoration is also something that you
can do
um you know but i i would be wary of the
contemporary art like
wary of art which is which is extremely
cynical and ironic
and kind of these double triple ironies
you know
uh i would be very cynical about i would
very cautious about putting that up in
your house
just because uh you know the things that
you have around you will affect you
all right so jael says hello jonathan i
remember a video with john varvakey and
i think paul vander clay and jp marxo
from what i can remember at one point in
the video john gets excited when he
finds out that perhaps he can believe in
miracles
if you can equate them with the placebo
effect i've seen you and others talk
about the placebo effect on emergence
and all that stuff
before but i'm afraid it's all a bit
over my head is it possible to get a
dumbed-down explanation
of how miracles relate to the placebo
effect all right
um
so and then he said do you have any idea
when john vivek's religion
is coming out when's it dropping i don't
know what you're referring to there i
hope he's not starting a religion but
um so how does the the miracles relate
to the placebo effect it's actually
quite
simple is that
helping people see the placebo effect
and helping them think about it
is forcing people to see something
which everybody recognizes as existing
right so everybody recognizes
that the placebo effect is a real thing
because it's there in
research you know if you're going to
have a proper research on medicine you
need to include
the placebo effect in your research
because they people recognize it
as an actual phenomena but it's a
phenomena
whose causality is not
the mechanical causality it's a it's a
causality of meaning
and so what causes this the placebo
effect
is meaning is meaning authority
right trust that's what causes the
placebo effect
and so those things right meaning
trust authority
that's what miracles are made of or
medical miracles are made
of faith authority
and meaning because miracles don't
aren't just freak events
all the miracles of christ are extremely
meaningful they are
showing the pattern of reality and so
that's why it's
well that's why the placebo effect is
like a it's like a wedge
in the world where in the materialistic
world you can point to something
which no one can deny and doesn't
function
by materialistic material um
causality in in the kind of mechanical
billiard ball type of causality that
people think about
so that's why it's important and that's
why it can help people
understand we're not saying that the
placebo effect is
is miracles we're saying that
understanding the placebo effect
can help you understand how there are
events
in the world that happen through meaning
and that's what a miracle is
just at a higher level than placebo
effect you know
all right and so dortia asked hi
jonathan have you watched the anime
fullmetal alchemist brotherhood
so no i haven't a lot of people have
told me i should watch fullmetal
alchemist
and so maybe who knows i don't know i i
i i don't watch a lot of stuff and so
i'm actually watching some people will
probably get annoyed with this but i am
actually watching
uh the second season of uh attack
uh what is it attack on titan or
whatever the titan
uh show it's very violent and disturbing
but
there's a really interesting play
understanding of
how the giants work and how the walls
you know i won't spoil anything for you
but like that there's a relationship
between the walls and the
giants and there's like there's
infiltration and
so it's all about the inside of the
outside and how some people from the
outside can
can help fight off the outside and stuff
so it's actually an interesting
structure
in terms of that but maybe one day i'll
watch that i don't know so
like i said i don't watch a lot of a lot
of stuff
so nom grande says in the beginnings of
christianity the cross was originally
not depicted with christ on it
it over time this changed can you speak
of why this happened
and or the symbolism and effect of this
change on christianity
and how this changed the christian view
of christ and the symbol of the cross in
general
so i think
so i think one of the things that we can
understand of how christianity lays it
laid itself out is that
we have to understand we have to
understand early christianity as a
really
it was an initiatory group
that is in order to have access to what
the christians
really believed you had to be initiated
into the church
so it wasn't like today it wasn't like
preachers on every corner or
me on the internet you know just
revealing the mysteries of
of the church that never that didn't
happen so you had
you see it it's still contained in the
liturgy today in the orthodox liturgy
where you have
the first part of the liturgy the
liturgy of the word which it was meant
for
even people who were in christian
catechumens but even not anybody but
catechumens that that weren't in
communion and then those would leave and
then there would be the liturgy of the
faithful
where the highest mysteries of the
christian uh
church was revealed and so you see that
for example there are early texts called
mystagogies
and these mysticalities what they were
were when someone was a catechumen and
was entering into the church
once they were baptized then
they would be told like the real
mysteries
but before that they weren't told it's
like you get the sense
even that maybe some people didn't know
about communion
before they were baptized so when they
were baptized
all of a sudden they were faced with the
mystery of eating the blood and body of
christ
you know it's like you can almost get
that sense that that's what that's what
was going on
but so the idea is that the the
crucified christ is
the highest mystery there is it's like
do you realize how scandalous that image
is like can you even
fathom how scandalous it is to have
this dead body on
the cross and say this is an image of
your god it's like
it's a very scandalous insane
proposition which can
only be approached to very slowly and
very
methodically and that a person has to be
brought into that mystery and initiated
into it
and so now we take it for granted um and
i think that that's what happened is i
think that
the mystery of christ as the church
became more accepted and as the church
became the standard culture then the
mystery of the cross
and the scandal of the cross was was
accepted
and and the mystery of the cross became
available to people and
kind of people lived in it and so it it
then became possible to represent christ
on the cross whereas before it would
have been like
too high a mystery to show people like
in
explicitly like that um but there are
some like early
representations of christ on the cross
um that are very schematic like fifth
century
images there are there are few but often
even at the beginning christ would be
shown
uh like with his eyes open sometimes
wearing like
like a kind of royal vestment and it's
really late like 9th century 10th
century
you start to see uh images of christ uh
dead on the cross like the jew crucifix
um
seems i think it's like 9th century i
think or late 8th century
and so it starts to come in later but i
think that's what it is but i mean i
might be wrong but that's my that's my
uh
take on it
all right so emin says jonathan could
you speak more about the meaning of sex
and its effects on binding two people
together
how does the soul get bound and what are
the patterns
of the binding and unraveling and so
i mean the scripture doesn't say that
that uh
that the soul gets bound together it's
not like the two souls become one soul
um but that you get bound in the body
that is you become
one body and
you become one so it's some people it's
not that complicated
to kind of understand it it's like
what a body is it's like i really love
father stephen from
the uh the podcast uh the lord of
spheres podcast called when he talks
about the body as a
nexus of possibilities or a nexus of
powers and so
it's and and by the way i think i use
that when the the i used that exact
wording in the
the talk with jordan peterson kind of
like a little uh
tip of the hat to father steven there
but um
so you can understand that when you join
two bodies together
the successful joining of the two bodies
together is
an extra body it's a it's a growing of
the possibilities and so you join
together
with with someone in the body and then
you
have fruits it's like that's
that's that that's the most immediate
way to understand it is that it really
does bind you
with someone uh but it's like you don't
necessarily have to just have
a child every time but it's like you can
understand that the fact that this is
what this is doing
by joining you to someone and then
having more body
it's like that's one of the things that
sex is it's it really is a
joining and so then but it's it happens
kind of in the hierarchy this idea of
the man
as the head of the family and the woman
is more on the body side you would say
and so the though you could understand
that when a
when a man and a woman join together the
woman becomes
the vessel becomes the body which
receives
the receives the the the seed of the man
and so
she she becomes one body with him in the
sense that she becomes like the
she becomes the the home of his
body right so so
i mean i want to become explicit here
but it's like she becomes the home of
his body and so
that is how they become one body right
one
so something coming from above and
something coming from below
joining together in that sense right so
that's
that's that's it and so and so
but it's a real thing like it's a real
thing and and there are subtle
aspects to it it's not just like a
carnal thing there's a
subtle joint there are subtle aspects to
the body that aren't just
uh carnal and right uh there are subtle
affects of you that get joined together
with someone
in in a sexual union that are very hard
to dissolve
and so that has to do with memory it has
to do with attraction
and and uh let's say
um connection right and so those things
are not
physical in the grossest sense but
they're they're nonetheless
part of your nexus of possibilities so
you're
what you your memory is an easiest way
to understand it's like if you if you
have
intercourse with someone then that is
going to be part of you
for forever it's like you can't get rid
of that it's
it's part of your story it's part of
your memory and then if you bring that
if you go if you then you have a
relationship with someone else you're
going to bring that memory into that
relationship
and it will be damaging to that
relationship
because because you'll compare because
you'll
because you'll you'll still have some
longing for for
for that which was there before you'll
be so it's a dangerous game to play
in terms of if you really want to join
together in a union
with with your spouse it's a dangerous
game to play if you come in
with all these other experiences because
it's going to be part of that
it's going to be like a like parasites
in your relationship that are gonna be
there
so um all right so christopher mihaly
says can you
clarify your dragons are more real than
dinosaur statement
and so kind of like that there was a
question like that a little earlier
there
um it seems pretty obvious doesn't it
that dragons are more real than
dinosaurs i mean
dragons contain dinosaurs dinosaurs
don't contain dragons
so dragons are more real than dinosaurs
all right so let me explain it a little
more so the dragon
category involves the fact that you
don't know what those things are
completely
and so they're the chaos element of
these bones that are
strewn about in the world and that are
there on the ground
the unknown aspect of it is contained in
the category of dragon
these monsters that that you don't
totally understand
one of the funniest things is like to
see like the artists
the scientific rendition of dinosaurs
and how they keep changing
all the time and they think that they're
getting closer i don't know whatever
they they imagine
what the dinosaurs look like and they
think that they're somehow being precise
about it
and it's just hilarious you know what
colors were dinosaurs and then
we have all these images and we think
that they're real
but the dragon is more real because the
dragon says
this is part this is part fantasy like
this is this is the way that we're
representing the dragon is a fantasy
because we've never seen a dragon
like or if we have in some vision or
some some ecstatic state or whatever
uh and so because of it it means that
all of these elements
are more joined together in the right
way they more
they more cont they contain more reality
than this like weird this weird they act
as if
people like the scientists act as if
dinosaurs are like species
in the world today that they can just
like
almost as if they they still exist and
then they can just like
put them in categories and they can tell
us how they what they ate and like
what their digestive system was like and
you hear these scientists
make all these hilarious statements uh
then then then you know like in two
weeks or in a few months
then they'll realize that they're wrong
and then now they'll have a better idea
of what these dinosaurs look like sorry
guys i don't you got
so i i always feel bad when i i become
extremely cynical about you know
scientists so all right
okay man so the wakeful
says dear jonathan is there a conflict
between the path of theosis
as experienced by the mystic and the
social solidity of a church
it indicates that mystics who have
claimed to experience theosis often
claim
to shed the specific forms
ritual litany etc that provide a church
with structure to quote meister icard
whoever sees god in a definite mode
accepts the mode and misses god
who is hidden in that mode whoever seeks
god without a mode however grasps him
as he is in himself
so this is this is actually like you
could say that this is how you
differentiate a real
mystic from a fake one it's in your
question
so i'm gonna tell you guys like a little
secret about mystics
and so yes that's true
it's true that the the theosis leads to
an experience of god that is beyond all
form and so even in hezykasm
you know the experience of divine light
is without image
right it is it's a it's something which
is beyond any
experience in the strict sense
and so you don't they actually don't
have vision there's no vision
there's just this direct
encounter with the infinite and so there
there there's no form
right that's how the highest mystic
encounters god
but that no form
right that that highest aspect
when it comes back down it always takes
body
it always takes form that's why the
world exists
right that's why the world
is also an expression of the infinite
and so you can imagine that
the highest aspect of something
is kind of like a negation of that thing
or negation of the particularities of
that thing
always okay so the highest aspect of a
cup
is the negation of the particular
aspects of the cup
or it has to be or else if it's just the
particular aspects of the cup
then it's not going to be a cup
so all identity functions that way so
you can imagine that as you get higher
and higher it gets more and more
lofty and then when you reach the
highest sphere where all of reality
itself
is like stopping and then and then this
last move where you move into the
formless then
it's like that's how reality works but
nonetheless
when you come back down it all lays
itself out
and so if you want to know the
difference between
uh let's say a real mystic and a fake
mystic
is the fake mystic is going to be an
iconoclast
the fake mystic is going to is going to
to
to say that authority is wrong that the
church is all
off that that that uh all the forms of
the church are evil
and so it's like
that's that's the difference and it's
really interesting to see
like because you've heard people like
that probably today you've heard people
like that
that will say something like i believe
god is beyond all forms you know
and therefore i don't participate in any
forms and so the real mystic will do
that
it's a in the in an ascetic sense but
then nonetheless
they they the the the let's say the true
mystics in the orthodox church will
still take communion if it's
if it's possible for them they will
still participate in the church services
if it presents itself to them but they
don't have to
they wouldn't they don't need to right
there they are beyond that
but they still will if they descend they
will
descend in the body right they won't
they won't hate they won't hate the form
they won't hate authority
you know um anyways so
think about that because you i know like
there's so many like
nero spiritualists today that are
exactly that and that's the problem with
the gnostics
the gnostics that's one of the problems
with the gnostics is that they had they
had a glimpse of this mystery that god
is beyond
all forms but then they weren't able to
come back down and see that the forms
are also
are also af manifestations of the divine
at the level
at which they were and not and not
always
just these evil corruptions of of uh
of the divine principle so
it's a big deal all right so chase and
lindsay asked hey jonathan
in your recent video with dr paula
baddington boddington the notion that
there is a priestly cast bringing their
idols into the world
to machines was brought up this is a
pattern i have felt for several years
now however one thing
i have always wondered and can't pin
down as if these people are consciously
aware
that they are serving as priests for
some kind of hidden deities
i find it hard to believe some of these
techie people are consciously
sacrificing to bring
about long dead pagan gods to ruin our
lives
are there any stories in history or
scripture about
people who unintentionally serve as
priests for foreign gods without
realizing it
the closest story i can think of is king
solomon and the gods
of his many wives yes but it feels
different than what's going on right now
thank you for any insight
and so yes i think that your insight
about king solomon is actually a pretty
good insight
in the sense that and and the
relationship
not just the king solomon but the
relationship in
scripture uh between the idea of taking
foreign wives
and the danger of taking foreign wives
and then serving foreign gods
there's that's exactly what it is it's
that
i think most people they're probably
some that are more aware than we think
and
we hope not but i would say most people
they don't they serve the god for the
goods that
that they get right they they're willing
to serve the god
to get the goods right it's so so it's
like they just see the goods
they just see the beautiful woman they
don't care about the god
if they they have to serve the god to
get the beautiful woman
they're like yeah whatever i just want
the beautiful woman and i think that
that's what
that's what's going on in a lot of this
it's like they
they know that they can get massively
rich
and massively powerful by engaging in
this behavior
and that's what's driving them and they
don't necessarily
totally uh understand or realize
that they're being duped as well you
know
so that's at least what i think but you
know who knows
who knows how explicit some of this
stuff is
in those spheres
so aj says hey jonathan i've heard you
say a few times that we did not learn
our lesson from world war
ii and that we're headed not to
toward a not good place my question is
can anything except a major catastrophe
change our course
because i want to believe that enough
good art enough powerful stories
told from the right framework can make a
difference similar to how jordan
peterson said the gulag archipelago
helped bring down the soviet union and
so
look aj i think you're right
and i think that that's what we have to
do
but i think there's gonna be suffering
like
i i i can't see any other way
and even with with uh soulja nitsan like
i mean that didn't come easy that book
didn't come easy to him that book
cost him a chunk of his life you know
and a chunk of his
youth and a chunk of his energy and you
know a lot of suffering so
it's like i agree but um
but i don't think
i think there's they're gonna be
catastrophes and so hopefully
hopefully they'll be enough good to at
least
have some some arc
there amidst that
all right so anjo terpstra says
hey jonathan you've told that the
pattern of reality is so overwhelming
that only saints can access it what
struck me in this phrasing
was the connection between insight on
the spiritual pattern and spiritual
practice can you elaborate on this
to what extent does spiritual practice
support these insights
i'm asking this because then probably
more
of your viewers engage with symbolism
and the pattern of reality from a more
didactical angle
yes most of my insights are derived from
you they are taught although it affects
my spiritual life these insights are not
derived from my spiritual life
how does spiritual practice are becoming
more wholly related to insight on the
pattern
what is your personal practical
experience um and so
i think your question is is very good
because
the idea of spiritual practice is pr is
participation
and so like i talk about participation
but
there's a difference between talking
about participation and
actually engaging in participation and
so
spiritual practice whether it's being
part of a
communion of saints whether it's
you know attending services and and then
also
the more personal spiritual practices
like fasting
like praying like the jesus prayer you
know as you saw in the in the video
and and attention to your sins attention
to god
all of these spiritual practices what
they'll do is that they'll
they'll make the pattern
part of you like you in the sense that
you will
be experiencing it and you will be
transforming you'll be transformed
so that then that will become
the the the soup like the thing you're
in it'll become like the the
the world that you actually live in and
not just something you think about
and so the idea like you know the idea
that the saints
that see the world transfigured you know
that they look at the world if you read
saint maximus
it talks about reaching a spiritual
state where
when you see when you're experiencing
reality
you always can see the will of god
hidden in
things like you can always see the
spiritual
uh the logie the spiritual
realities or the spiritual reasons for
things as you are engaging with them
and you also see that they're not in
contradiction but not just c but it's
like experience it
so so so yeah so that's the difference
and i think that
it's probably i hope that it's helpful
to know it in terms of your mind
so that you think it's important enough
to then engage in the spiritual
practices that will
bring you to live it that will bring you
to actually experience it and
and it have it be more than just theory
all right so kevin patterson says
sorry i'm just looking at how many
questions are left here what time is it
10 30. all right
so kevin patterson says to guard against
evil look some people wear evil eye
talisman
their guard into adultery people wear
wedding bands yes
reminder to self signal to others what
talisman can an unmarried person use to
guard against
promiscuous activity both succumbing to
it warning off advances
imagine such a talisman would also help
a person lower their paranoid suspicion
of predatory behaviors and others well
wear a cross dude
that's that that's probably what you
should just do just wear a cross
um you know
so and take it seriously like if you
wear a cross then you you're in a
situation where you
you are going to take your clothes off
but then you you have to take your cross
off
or you see it and it's there dangling in
front of you
like hopefully if you've taken that
cross seriously it'll be a reminder
of where not to go so that's what i
would say to do
so ryan pinkham says does
the hail mary have the same sort of
structure as the jesus prayer
um and so i would say
no it's not the same structure
uh but i would have to
i should probably make a video about
that i don't i actually wouldn't want to
go into that right now
it would be something that i would i
would like to think about
more uh profoundly and then talk about
uh
talk about um the words of the angel
it's like well first of all you can see
the difference like the hail mary
is coming from above and it's talking
about that which is below right
because hail mary is is spoken by the
angel gabriel
uh and so whereas the jesus prayers is
talked about from below moving to above
if you understand that the jesus prayer
is patterned on the public in prayer
that it's like you know god have mercy
on me a sinner
then it's it's like above looking below
whereas the hail mary is
strangely enough like from the angel
looking down
upon the the mystery of uh of the
of the space of revelation you could say
all right
so jason gadawaltz asked could you talk
about
discernment in relation to other virtues
also please make a video on numbers
you talk about discernment in relation
to other virtues
i mean i can talk about discernment in
the sense that discernment
is the capacity to identify things
properly and
and that's obviously very important to
identify the origin of things
you know to know what they are truly
and so i think that that's really
important in terms of
when you meet people and also when you
encounter certain experiences when you
have feelings
to be able to name them properly so you
can understand something like
discernment is something like the
capacity
to properly name things and so
definitely there's a difference between
discernment and
other values because discernment is
directly related to
to uh to knowledge and to to uh
intelligence so it's a little different
all right so charlie longoria says
what are your thoughts on the bible
project i've been finding this channel
extremely helpful in reading the
scripture again after many years
especially the old testament
yeah i like a lot of the stuff they're
doing i
actually tried to have uh the main guy
on my channel i wrote them and asked
them
if you'd be willing to uh to talk to me
but they said he wasn't taking
interviews so i guess that's not gonna
happen
but i think they're interesting the most
interesting thing about
them is
is that is that i i feel like this is
this i
i hate when i always have to not but i
always have to criticize
uh prosthetism but one of the greatest
one of the greatest
really fascinating thing that's
happening right now and i'm excited
about it i'm really positive about it
is how several protestants whether it be
the bible project whether it be
uh you know uh what's his name the the
through new eyes james jordan
and the you know or there are several
people that are seriously
kind of seeing the patterns and are
now noticing the patterns of scripture
and i feel like the bible project is
part of that
but there's the thing that i think
they're missing
is that they somehow don't see
how it's the pattern of everything like
they they they really
they see the pattern in scripture and
they they do want to
do want to get let's say uh
some morals some morality to it but
it feels like they don't see how
how like i said like it's the pattern of
everything and so
how it then how you can use example like
i i rarely hear these people
give examples in common day common
experience
of what the bible is doing and so
that's where i feel like like they're
missing something but maybe
like maybe i'm wrong i don't i also
don't want to be but
i would love to talk to these people and
and see what they think of that
so king of rat kings
is it wise to say that story is akin to
mathematics and as much as two plus two
equals four it's both true and real
despite the fact that
numerical qualities only manifest that's
a secondary property attached to a
primary phenomenon
available to the senses and so
i mean i would say yes it's related to
mathematics in the sense that it's
that stories are related to uh
related to proportion and they're
related to uh
patterns and so it's like just like
mathematics is
is a display of pure display of patterns
you know in that same way then stories
are more let's say embodied display of
patterns
so all right don palermo says
my community is riddled with a tendency
and reaction in reaction to the idle
machine of self-help culture expressed
in organic food movement to instead
celebrate being seriously indiscriminate
about what we put into the body
yeah zero discrimination is supposedly
the
evidence of true liberation and faith
well that's odd
i see truth in this tendency and
something deeply bothers me
i consider the purpose of sustaining the
body to host heaven and
also the meaning to die purposefully
maybe the blurring of the lines
of the category for what is food is a
uniquely modern
issue is it relevant to my
question which i failed to clarify
succinctly that the desert fathers went
without
but did not do the opposite to put
anything in yes exactly so i would say
that
there's a difference between fasting and
eating anything like
you know there's something
the idea that because it's not important
like because in the sense that because
uh
because it's more important to to focus
on spiritual things and and
and all that the idea that then you
could just eat anything this is
absolutely stupid like it's stupid
because
because eating is a passion like eating
is not just a
fuel right and so it's like you have
desires to eat things and so so the idea
that you could just eat anything
is also showing you that you just give
in to your desires like discipline in
eating
is actually a is actually a kind of
pointing to spiritual discipline like
that's why there's fasting in the church
and and so and so
the idea of not eating certain things
and and not eating all the time or not
eating certain quantities
is is actually very important in order
to
to tame your passions and to tame your
body so that you're
you're able to not be focused on it so
someone who says
somebody who says something like you
know it's only god is important doesn't
matter what you eat and so he eats
anything
you might realize that that person is
more of a slave
of what it is they're eating that they
would wish to admit to themselves
so uh so yeah all right
so agar's mom says hi jonathan how would
you describe the difference between
improvement of one's psychological
well-being versus deification
of that person are they similar
processes are they completely different
do they have the same goals thanks they
don't they don't
have the same goals uh
it's like one of the problems of the the
idea of
of psychological well-being the way we
understand it today is that it's
it's it's a it's actually sometimes
is not helpful because we have this idea
that for example i've talked about
self-esteem before the problem of
self-esteem and the problem of
of seeing people as like little gods
and thinking that you somehow have to
attain a kind of
happy state right it's like you read the
church fathers and they will tell you
that
it's like this happy state that we kind
of look for
and you know i mean i'm guilty of that
all the time i'm not i'm not trying to i
don't want to judge anybody but
that happy state that we're that we're
going for that that doesn't lead to
holiness at all
and uh and uh you know you the state
of a saint is something more like a kind
of
ecstatic pain no that can't i couldn't
say i didn't say it that way
it's more like something like a kind of
living in the a kind of sorrow for your
sins
which is also filled with uh with a kind
of joy of being connected to god
and so it's actually quite self-depre
deprecatory like it's actually quite uh
seeing yourself as nothing really and
then being being connected to god
um but then the thing about that is that
what happens
to people who really see themselves as
nothing isn't isn't low self-esteem
it's actually a healthier kind of
it's actually it actually will end up
manifesting itself as a kind of
full use of your capacities and a and a
and a true use of your capacities and
not a delusion
you know not the disappointment of of
not accomplishing things because you
think you're better than what you are
like that kind of that kind of problem
of the
of the kind of psychological well-being
thing um
so yeah and i say that but i'm like i'm
all i'm all in that world like i'm not
as i'm not a
ascetic you know i i try to have a
comfortable lifestyle and i
you know and so it's like i i want to be
careful but i it's not the same as
deification that's for sure
the road of defecation is a is a
is a harsher one
all right so what j jacobus wrote
rhodania says what is the symbolism of
volcanoes
could they be pointless mountains
representing pride
eg pride taken over pompeii or topless
hierarchies erupting open doors to
deadly chaos
to be interesting i really haven't
thought about volcanoes so much
they definitely have something to do
with uh with like
you know the lower fires like erupting
you know and causing chaos into the
world and so maybe you could understand
something like volcanoes something like
a revolution
maybe that'd be a good way to understand
it and that's why it also appears as
like a mountain
but then this mountain like spews out
this like
this lower fire i don't know i haven't
thought about it i just should think
about it more before i speak
all right so erie fisher asks hi
jonathan sorry this is question is that
we skate for youtube i'm curious about
your thoughts on the symbolism of the
relationship between christianity and
islam
i was very interested to read in
dominion about how the muslims consider
themselves the descendant of ishmael
and also how tom described islam as a
kind of wedge that was
driven between east and west christendom
yeah contributing to the schism
what do you think is there some hostile
brothers things going
on there
well let's just say this like the early
christians the early
christians that were there at the
beginning of islam saw islam as a as a
christian
uh heresy that's how saint john the
damascene
saint john of damascus saw islam
and in terms of history that is
absolutely true our knowledge of history
and our understanding of history
it's in terms of islam is so twisted
by the enlightenment it is so twisted by
the enlightenment because the
enlightenment
tried to use the
crusades as a bludgeon
to smash over the head of christianity
and so
in doing that and also because
there's also because the after the the
the split
of uh between east and west the
the west wanted to portray itself as
kind of this like kind of all-powerful
thing especially in the enlightenment
too
like in the enlightenment wanted to
erase constantinople like
just erase its memory as if it never
existed
because it's a it's embarrassing to
think about constantinople when your
purpose
is to bash you know how dark the ages
were before you because
then what do you do with constantinople
which was this glorious city
you know until until uh until things
started to fall apart when the
the the islamic invasion started to
happen and so
yeah it's like the the the if you think
about it just practically like
the islam basically surrounded
christianity and then
made it difficult for everything to
happen like for communication to happen
for trade to happen between the
different aspects of
of the of the christian world and so
it's like
yeah that's that's that's one of the
things that happened
all right so benjamin kinkade says i
recently listened to your conversation
with dr paula boddington
on the ethics and narrative surrounding
ai i'm wondering if you have any advice
for those currently working in tech what
can we do to help steer things
in a direction that's good
um pray like pray a lot
oh man that's like i feel like just some
pastor that's giving generic advice but
i would say that to be i would say that
if to be attentive to be attentive to
your
actions to your intentions to be
attentive to the reason why you're doing
things
and uh and to pray and so
because it's it's it's not gonna be easy
it's gonna it's gonna get
all this is gonna get worse it's gonna
get very difficult
so so uh yeah i don't know man
i mean
i don't think tech is bad like i i think
tech is
good i think ultimately it can be it can
serve the good but
i think that it's definitely not looking
it's not looking bright at least but
look i mean here you guys are
listening to what i'm saying because of
tech so it's like i don't want to be the
guy knocking tech
because because obviously it has
increased
power it has increased the power of
reach that anybody can have and so it
has
definitely has uh definitely has value
but uh but for sure ai is uh
yeah it's scary so yeah
but the one thing i do i wanted to say
because i kind of went
with the question about islam
it doesn't change that there are some
like in within
let's say islamic art there are some
amazing things that were done
and that if i read some i read i've read
some
islamic uh writers that have
a very powerful understanding of reality
you know and so
i always kind of talk about how
i think that i think that as as
christians it's good to
be capable of seeing the sparks
of light which are in the surroundings
and but just be careful to not
let's say to not make them your own in
the sense that you're able to notice the
places where there's light
you know in in other cultures and other
religions and other
in ancient myths and in weird weird
weird places
and so but it's also but it's also about
being able to kind of see that without
you know without then throwing up your
own world into the air and saying okay
well it's all the same then let's all
just do whatever and
and let's just all be universalists
because that leads to nothing like it
leads to
it leads to porridge um
and so so yeah so maybe that's the last
thing i could say about that
all right guys and so yeah those were
all the questions and it's
10 to 11 but i will go into
the super chats and uh
let's see i never have them ready
because i never think about this
all right so i'm not following the chat
for some reason i wasn't going down
there
all right so here we go
all right so luigi for
five dollars u.s asks what does the
burning bush of exodus symbolize
and so that that's a that's a
complicated question but you could
the easy way to understand it is
that
god manifesting himself in the world
while letting the multiplicity of the
world continue to
exist right so
that's the best way to understand it
it's like the mystery of
how god can manifest himself without
destroying the particularities right
with that unity can manifest itself
without destroying particularities
that's that's what the burning bush is
about
and you know and it reaches culmination
in the perpetual virginity of the virgin
which remains completely untouched
and is not never taken up but
nonetheless becomes the place and the
body
for the divine logos all right
um
so the golden threads for 20 says please
chill more for your odyssey
i believe it'll be a great space you can
sync it to auto upload youtube videos
it has a better ui than bitchute and is
not as vulnerable
i'd also use your name for the channel
easier to find i think i do have an
odyssey channel don't i
i i i've told you guys that i'm working
with uh
with a company called uh content safe
and they
they're the ones who are running my uh
my website um
it's the same the same people his name
is matthew raymer
and uh they've been kind of putting my
content up on bit shoot and on different
platforms
so i mean i thought i had an odyssey
channel maybe i don't i don't know
i'll check it out all right so ray
fleming for
five uh pounds says how do you find the
correct balance between telling the
truth and the virtue of not exposing
everything a la noah getting drunk um
and so it's it's pretty simple it's not
that simple it's
it's hard in the immediate moment is
that
truth al also has to do with the reason
why you say something
and so if you can examine the reason why
you would say something
that is also part of whether or not
something should be said
so it's not only about being factually
accurate it's about
why would you say that in the in the in
the first place
right because there are plenty of facts
that you don't say
that are real like you know all the
random things that are happening around
you right you don't
go up to someone and tell them it's like
you tell them that oh there's a fly you
know
on the counter like you don't say that
and so the answer is
why would you say something and that's
how you
are able to to uh
find the the the balance and so
sometimes there are moments
where if you don't say a certain fact
you are you you are acting immorally
because
that fact has a as it has a danger to it
or has a scandal to it or has
something that has to be revealed right
and so
if you see i don't know you're walking
down the street and you see
uh someone like robbing uh you know
pickpocketing someone
and then you don't say anything because
you don't want to get involved
then not revealing that fact is like a
lie right it's
not telling the truth there it becomes
like a lie but
so it's always it's all about the reason
why you say something or not say
something
like if you don't say something just
because you want to get out of trouble
right but you can also not say something
because you don't want to get someone
else into trouble and that
that like you you can cover someone
sometimes if you do it out of love
and you do it you know in in a good way
so that
so it just really depends on the reason
um
so jamie cummings for 9.99 u.s says
hi jonathan any thoughts you'd like to
share on hegel
i have to tell you that certainly after
two hours of speaking i'm not going to
talk about angle
sorry jamie
um so francisco caldes for two euros
says why god orders a man to be killed
for working on a saturday all right this
is this brings in a harder discussion
which is that
one of the problems with people reading
the old testament is that they get hung
up on
the on how many times god says to kill
someone
for breaking breaking a law and
by doing that you are you you actually
obscure
at some point you don't you're not able
to see
what's being said like what is it what
is it that
is is being talked about
so a better way to approach it is to
understand
just to say why is it forbidden to work
on a saturday
and and why is it important because if
you just say why to be killed it's like
in the old testament
the problem the problem when when people
think about like these tribes in the
deserts is that they don't understand
what it meant like you're there's no
prisons when you live
in a desert tribe right there's nothing
to do with people
that break the rules you can punish them
to a certain extent right you can make
them
you can try to make them have
reparations
but at some point it's like there's
nothing to do you can't put people in
jail and keep them there if they do
things and so
it's like this the idea of not working
on the sabbath
is about preserving the cycle
it's about preserving the the normal
running of
of things and so you have to leave the
residue
you have to leave the remainder and not
touch it right and that's super
important because if you touch the
remainder
if you try to integrate the remainder
you're actually bringing about the end
of your world
you're actually accelerating a process
which will lead to the destruction of
your of your identity
right and so so you have to leave it
all right so joshua anderson for 499
says do you think it's possible that eve
was tempted by the serpent and the guard
in genesis
on a sexual level um and so
i don't think so i i think that that's
really
okay so the the problem with this
the the problem with this is that it's
also because it's like
it's also because people don't don't
understand all the symbolism of what
of what uh the sexuality is and so
if you want to understand it this way
you could you could say that
eve does join herself to the serpent in
the sense that
the serpent tells her something and then
she believes him and
acts in coordination with the belief
in the word of the serpent and so the
serpent
is so she believes the serpent rather
than believe
god and so she joins herself with the
serpent and then
becomes a body for his
will for his being right and so in that
sense
you could say that she joined herself
with the serpent but
you definitely do not have to think of
it in terms of a
of a physical union between the beast
and the and
and or or something that is like
explicit in the way that that
people want to think about that and but
it
it you could understand it analogically
as the fact that eve does join herself
with the serpent
and so so so so there is a
there is a how can i say this there is
something
an analogous to sexual symbolism in
what's going on
but it's not directly right just in the
same way when i
when if you read the story of christ and
the samaritan there's sexual symbolism
going on
during the whole discussion between
christ and the samaritan
where he talks about the fountain of of
pure water and the well which is
referencing proverbs where it talks
about joining yourself with the foreign
woman
which is what he's doing in that story
but it doesn't mean that he had sex with
her
it doesn't have to mean that right it
just means that
the symbolism because it's fractal and
it works at different levels
that it that it that it scales at
different levels it doesn't have to
become
you know just like the fact that we are
the bride of christ
doesn't mean that jesus has sex with us
in like a physical
sense why am i saying this like why do i
have to say this
i don't have to say this all right but
i'm saying it anyways all right so
ulysses k
hughes for five year olds sorry guys man
alive
for five euros says is the holy spirit
the feminine aspect of the holy trinity
if not what is the feminine aspect of
god
and so no the holy spirit is not the
feminine aspect
of the holy trinity and so
the feminine aspect of god
that's what theosis is about guys
theosis is about that
it's about i think it's about that
i don't know what to say all right
so the golden thread says usd for usd
five dollars given your fluency in
multiple languages that the cosmos
manifests itself differently
to you according to which logos you're
thinking speaking
in um i mean i don't know that many
languages i know
two and a half i would say
uh and so the there definitely is a
difference
right in terms of the manifestation it's
actually helpful to know several
languages because it
helps you to see how uh
the meanings of things all they kind of
point up also
above the the language and so it can
help you see
how the way of meaning embodies itself
definitely affects how you relate to the
world um but it also can help you see
that
that they they point above they point
beyond each
themselves you know um
all right so luca irimadza for five
dollars canadian
says our edm raves like the anti-church
the structures seem similar with the
dj's the priest the stage is the altar
and the altar boys are the tech i mean
yeah for sure i mean in the sense that
that so many of the modern so many of
the contemporary kind of
these types of events are like let's say
parodies of religion you know
and so a rave is one example but there
are others you know
burning man and all that kind of stuff
are all these kind of parodies of
religion
um
so v2 zui um
for cf chf5 i don't know what that is a
question
just by curiosity why did you choose
orthodoxy rather than catholicism
would convince you of orthodoxy rather
than catholicism so
i mean there are several aspects one is
obviously theosis
first then there is the iconography
which was still alive and so as an
artist i
i was so excited by the fact that i
could participate in the the traditional
language of
visual language of the church in terms
of architecture and and art and
and uh and the the iconography which was
still kind of the sacred language which
was
alive and um
and so i would say that and then i would
just say that
the theology that i read you know it's
like i just
read vladimirlovsky and was just
completely astounded by
by him and you know the hezekiasm the
jesus prayer
and uh you know that
the reliance on saint gregory of nisa
and saint max was the confessor and all
these saints that i really love
rather than saints that i mean i
appreciate
some of the western uh thinkers like
augustine i have appreciation for
augustine but i
i mean i think saint gregory nissa is
superior to augustine in terms of
what he brings like you know so
yeah so griswold grimm
chris walgrim i know who you are my
friend
so he says paintball for jesus for or
against i don't even know
what that means like i don't even know
what that means all right so david
franco jr
uh for 499 u.s says are you still taking
questions
and so i guess i am not anymore like i'm
stopped now so no more questions
and get through these and then we're
done so brandon samuel for five dollars
thoughts on joseph campbell
his massive god series is less
incredible than his other work
which makes you think he is not as new
age as rumored
i mean i don't know about joseph
campbell i would say joseph campbell
is one of the things that i read
in college like when i was reading
post-modern theory
someone gave me a copy of his interview
with uh
bill moyers and um and
it had an effect on me i have to say it
had an effect on me
it was probably part of my kind of
moving towards
pattern and moving towards um so
i mean he's not completely useless um
but
i would say that he's like a secondary
thinker
you know kind of so i haven't i i
haven't read that much
from him anyways but i always tell
people look
to be honest like get your insight where
you can get it and and so
true insight is true insight someone
sees a pattern in the story
that is useful if i don't care where it
comes from
if it's like some of the patterns that
jagdev noticed
in in the text in terms of the margin
was
right on like smack on he he could see
the pattern
i don't agree with his conclusion about
what it means that he perceived this
um and i think it's the same for people
like joseph campbell
or or other like
kind of psychoanalysis who tried to do
interpretations of fairy tales and that
kind of stuff
i think you can find some insight like i
said wherever it is you can find it
the idea is just about hierarchy it's
just about knowing
what you're attached to you know and
where your main
lights come from and then secondary
lights
you know it's okay um
all right so kana h asks a few months
into learning from you
and i'm wondering how we can test proof
theories on symbolism
versus just seeing a pattern and hoping
we're right
well the way that you the way that you
test a pattern
is if you you should watch with the
video i did with my brother
because materia and i did a discussion
about this
and uh the way that you test it is that
it has to
first of all it has to scale and so the
pattern has to
scale at different levels of reality it
has to be
found in other stories and in other
places and so if you just
find a pattern in one story and then you
can't think of other
stories that have the same pattern then
you're you're you're
you're in the wrong you're going the
wrong way like you're in the wrong
you're following the wrong thread okay
and so
that's the way you do it and so that's
why if you listen to my watch my video
you'll see i'm always skipping and so
like even if i'm in a conversation with
someone someone will say something
then i'll think of a pattern and then
i'll be like oh yeah and there's that
and there's that and there's that
and and so i'm skipping between
different
levels of reality so i if you listen to
my videos watch my videos you'll see
i'm often have like a biblical example
i'll try to find some example from
another story like a fairy tale or a
myth
and then some example from popular
culture
or from like everyday life and so trying
to kind of move across these different
levels
is the best way to test whether or not
the pattern you're seeing is
uh is an actual pattern or just some
fantasy you have
so chandler turner for five usd says
i've been reading
of ibn arabi's work has he referred to
the same god as christianity
and can i use his prayers
well look chandler i have a lot of
respect for ibn arabi's
writings and uh you know i think that
he's probably within islam
he is probably the person that has the
closest vision
of christ and of god as we find within
uh christianity but having said that
i would i would not recommend that you
use
his prayers if you are a christian
because
why would you like why there are we have
christian prayers like why would you use
uh his prayers um and so it's a
dangerous thing to kind of
to skip around you know it's not a it
doesn't
it can lead us astray all right
so gustavo louise i guess
for 20 i guess from brazil
hugs from brazil uh tried to know the
work of
italo marseille his work here in brazil
is revolutionary in christianity
where jordan peterson was for the
english world he is for the latin world
well
i will check them out i've never heard
of him
all right so my brother and i are on
good terms he's struggling with being
happy in life i'm figuring
out how to but i don't know how to
communicate how i'm doing
it i'm worried he'd bach at
straightforward advice
any insights thanks that is so
natural phenomenon that question is
extremely vague and i
i'm sorry i don't know how to answer
that
because i don't know like i don't know
enough about
your brother and i don't know enough
about um
i don't know like i i i obviously if you
don't have authority in someone's life
it's probably a good idea not to give
people advice
that is that is for sure because it
rarely will be taken
well you know give advice to people who
trust you and
and who see you as having authority
that's the best way to give advice if
not then become that person right
become that person that your brother
sees as someone to look up to or to have
that has authority
and therefore you'll avoid that that
problem so it's an easy i'm giving you
an easy answer but
obviously i know these personal things
are difficult to deal with
all right so bastian for 699 canadian is
the symbol of the
eye looking at the viewer often in
clusters as a symbol of an oppressive
force
an example of rejecting god by those
authors looking at the viewer often
i'm not sure i understand that question
brastian symbol of the eye looking at
the viewer often in clusters
that's a symbol of an oppressive force
i'm sorry brad and i don't totally
understand your question
so i can't answer it all right so
brandon samuel
fres says
also joseph campbell said the story of
the grail knight
is the basis of western individualism
thoughts
um yeah i don't think that's
i don't like that i don't like that very
much at all
i think that the so there's a difference
between
so i understand why he would say that he
says that because
the the people because the the knights
who seek the grail
they they all go in their different
directions
so it's like they they kind of see the
grail where they see it
so the grail actually would manifest
itself to them right kind of where they
are
and so i understand what what
what he's trying to refer to but
i would say that it's more to
it's more a way of understanding that
that say the the
the glory of god or the presence of god
descends into the particular
and that it it it can manifest itself in
all
places right it's hidden in the world
like so the sparks of god are hidden
in reality and can be encountered where
you can encounter them right
it can be countered in the places where
you're capable of encountering them
but that grail is nonetheless a chalice
of communion and so
finding the grail should bring you in
communion with the others
and should become kind of bridged
towards other people and it kind of
bridge towards
a place where you come together and so
and so i don't agree
i don't agree that that that the grail
is the
beginning of western individualism
all right so exodus for five dollars u.s
ask which books would you recommend for
a 10 year
old um
which books would you recommend for a 10
year old i mean i would say
narnia and so obviously that's an easy
one
but there are other good stories like
19th century stories are some good
stories
like uh i think that the jungle book is
nonetheless good
and um you know fairy tales are 10 years
old you can still
have kind of more complex versions of
fairy tales
um yeah that's what i would say
so symbolic means says hello janet can
you go to sleep now you are allowed to
go to sleep symbolic memes
as long as you promise to continue
making funny memes on symbolism
all right shivra we stop people keep
putting in some uh
some super chats all right mike zazek
says
the good stories intentionally embrace
archetype and patterns of reality
as they're being written or they're more
subconsciously incorporated
i would say i would say that they
i would say to be careful to to be
explicit
i always tell people like study
symbolism and then if you're writing a
story don't think about
symbolism when you're writing it you
have to it has to kind of
come out and then you can you can you
can edit it later and you can look at it
what you wrote later and then see
whether or not you can tweak a few
things but uh if you try to think about
archetypes and symbolism when you're
writing a story you're not gonna succeed
it's gonna it's gonna come out horrible
all right okay so i
am gonna go guys so thanks thanks for
everybody popping in we're
we're at we're at two hours and 15
minutes
i for some reason i'm i i'm getting more
stamina as i'm doing these videos
and so um all right so thanks everybody
for your
so mike sazak says oh my gosh you're
like the first human being
that's ever gotten my last name right on
the first try huh interesting
all right so good night everybody it was
a lot of fun and so
uh so yeah so check out the the
the podcast with jordan tomorrow on
youtube
so share it comment we need positive
comments in there because there's
bound to be there's gonna be some
negative comments in there
so uh it was good to talk to everybody
thanks all the moderators to brad
and i think yeah elise is there she's
still awake
at this late time for her and so i
appreciate everybody
sorry to other people whose questions i
was struggling to answer
and sign up to the website like i said
so we can avoid censorship and so i will
talk to everybody very soon
all right let me i need to get on here
to stop it so
all alright bye everybody